there's a lot to unpack here and so we
thought we would stop with start rather
with an actual lawyer someone who knows
a lot about the Supreme Court our friend
Lori Ingram the host of the Ingram angle
on the Fox News Channel she joins us
tonight to assess Laura I just got to
ask you something that sort of Allied it
over because I know you know a lot more
about it than I do but the fact that
this was leaked you know how the court
Works how big a deal is that yeah what
the first thing that happened when I
clerked on the court the first day that
all the clerks from that term were all
together it's like 40 or so of us
chief justice rehnquist said to us if
you are thinking at any point in time of
of divulging what happens within uh the
walls of this court especially anything
about internal deliberations
your legal career is over I mean it is a
great privilege to clerk at that court
it's considered by many of the highest
you know highest honor you could have as
a young lawyer just leaving Law School
in my case
and and that's how you betray the trust
of the justices liberals conservatives
doesn't matter and the institution of
the Court uh it is it's never happened
before uh it's going to change the way
the court operates uh and liberal
justices conservative justices all
should come together
and Together release a statement saying
we condemn this we will find out who did
this and this will never happen again
and explain to the American people why
this matters I know they announced an
investigation today of the Marshall's
office and I'll look forward to seeing
where that leads but someone knows who
did this besides the leaker they just
but they just did this and look I don't
agree with Stephen Breyer but I I think
he's smart and I think he's interesting
and you know he's an American who got
the job legitimately he shouldn't be
forced out with a leak because people
don't like his skin color that happened
in very much the same way this did and
no one did anything about it or even
really noticed it
well because the liberals who claim to
be the Defenders of democracy as you
noted in the open today they're kind of
the anti-democrats
the euphemistic language Tucker is
everyone grabs up we're pro-choice we're
this no no they are the wrecking ball to
American democracy today imagine if the
case was reversed and we had heard
through a leak egregious leak that the
court was coming down the other way and
imagine if mobs of people descended at
the court screaming what could be
described as threatening language
towards some of the Justice or very
derogatory language oh you'd have Nancy
Pelosi and the whole crowd up there
today saying we need to wall off the
city again we need to put the fences
back up and this is those are the
insurrectionists trying to undermine the
legitimacy of the Court that's what they
would be saying today and tonight
so I I mean I I think abortion is one of
the saddest things I can imagine I
really think it's a tragedy and I mean
that some people think it's the road to
happiness but why shouldn't we have a
vote on it I mean I'm serious like if
you love abortion why wouldn't you
welcome a national vote that or state by
state vote that defines its parameters
Tucker you and I have been friends for I
don't know how long long time you
actually think these people
trust Americans to vote I mean really
vote on these types of issues if they
were so confident that this was so
popular a position they'd be like bring
it on let's let's see I mean all 50
states you bet everybody have your say
and that's democracy that's how it works
but they want to take a whole slate of
issues off the table from the American
people and it's not gonna this is not
going to be settled here they are going
to keep fighting and keep ramping up the
temperature but look it's a great it's a
great day for the pro-life movement
across this country those who've toiled
and prayed and done it the right way
overwhelmingly peacefully and
respectfully that is the process and
people should celebrate that tonight
that's right and we should not be
intimidated by the mob we've been
through this before they got everyone
back on their heels oh we can't do
anything about it yeah no we should not
put up with this stuff no violence
exactly period Laura Ingram it's great
to see you tonight thank you for doing
this you're welcome
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight